[Musique]
signe de détente en Corse blocus aérien
et maritime partiellement levé
manifestation dans le calme le
gouvernement nomme un
conciliateur politique et corruption
l'affaire des fausses rebondit l'ancien
maire d'exen Provence et trois autres
personnes
inculpées du génocide à l'occupation le
Cambodge renaet de ses cendres sous la
férule vietnamienne une équipe d'Antenne
2 revient de ce pays
oublié un espoir dans la lutte contre la
muscovicidose la plus fréquente des
maladies génétiques la greffe des
poumons expérience réussie sur des
enfants à
Marseille madame monsieur monsieur
bonsoir ce mercredi devait être la
journée des grandes manifestations en
Corse c'est aussi semble-t-il le début
d'une relative d'écrispation à Paris le
gouvernement fait deux pas de plus pour
calmer le jeu le Conseil des ministres
ce matin a décidé de nommer un
conciliateur pour aboutir à une
discussion sur les problèmes de fond et
d'autre part le dialogue va être renoué
avec les syndicats de fonctionnaires
dans l'île les manifestations prévues
ont bien eu lieu mais sans incident
àjeexo quelques 3000 personnes étaient
rassemblé devant le siège de l'Assemblée
Corse qui débattait des propositions du
gouvernement Jean-Pierre
mtivet ce devait être le grand
rendez-vous syndical à ajaxio ce matin
en fait il n'était que deux ou 3000 bien
moins que pour les manifestations de
mercredi dernier des barrages routiers
ont semble-t-il empêché les grevistes
des autres villes de rejoindre à
jaaction les slogans ne sont pas une
surprise ils sont bien sûr dirigé contre
les propositions du Premier ministre et
bien sûr on réaffirme sa détermination
nous sommes là
pour 15 jours Mo Moe la journée il vont
rester là devant l'Assemblée de Corse à
l'intérieur jeanpa de Donon il demande
au gouvernement de saisir l'urgence de
la
situation il peut il
do pour
compr
équbr marche la après 7h de délibération
les élus demanderont des indemnités
compensatrices et le classement de la
Corse en zone zéro mais à l'extérieur
les manifestants sont partis il est 18h
au même moment les pêcheurs d'ajaacio
lèvent le blocus du port
oui le blocus aérien et maritime de lîle
a été partiellement levé au cours de la
journée quatre vols étaient prévus en
fin de journée pour le continent et à
Bastia les pêcheurs ont levé leur
barrage dans le port sur place Françoise
Ji
aux première loge pour un spectacle
inattendu dans le port de Bastia la
levée du blocus des marins pêcheurs cet
après-midi ils ont largué les amars
déplacés leurs cinq chalutiers qui
barraent l'entrée du port depuis près
d'une semaine des pêcheurs calmés
apaisés par l'arrivée des ce soir d'un
envoyé spécial du ministère de la mer un
négociateur pour parler de leurs
revendications comme par exemple
l'effacement de leur dettes des pêcheurs
enfin qui se défendent de la chez les
grevistes de la fonction publique dont
ils se sont déclarés
solidaires nous avons levé le blocus je
vous dis dans un souci d'apaisement et
d'un retour au calme et mais nous
restons mobilisés les bateaux sont sur
place dans tous les ports de
l'île quelques instants plus tard le
Santa Regina un féri encré au large
depuis 5 jours tente d'accoster une
manœuvre pour rien des manifestant à
cour de toutes part et l'empêche de se
mettre à qu on a décidé qu'il ne
rentrerait pas part pour Marseille c'est
terminé et pourtant signe d'apaisement
ce matin les syndicats ont accepté de
laisser partir un bateau de Marseille le
cirnos il entrera ce soir à Bastia autre
signe de décrispation l'accueil
favorable fait à l'annonce ce matin en
conseil des ministres d'une rencontre
entre le directeur de la fonction
publique et les
syndicats nous allons saisir l'occasion
de rencontrer le directeur général de la
Fonction publique je crois que nous
sommes dans une impasse et que si le
gouvernement fait un geste pour en
sortir nous de notre côté nous
négocierons avec lui ce soir pour la
première fois Bastia depuis de nombreux
jours la journée s'achève dans une
ambiance un peu moins troublée et dans
deux communiqués séparés ce soir le
Parti communiste et la CGT appelle le
gouvernement à négocier avec les
syndicats un inspecteur général des
finances Michel Prada a donc été nommé
ce matin pour préparer les différentes
tables rondes annoncées par le Premier
ministre sur les problèmes spécifiques
de la Corse entre autres le problème des
prix qui explique en partie la grogne
des fonctionnaires et qui a poussé père
bergovois à saisir le Conseil de la
concurrence pourquoi la plupart des prix
sont-ils plus élevés en Corse que sur le
continent Véronique Oger prend deux
exemples l'essence consommée en Corse
est stocké dans deux dépôts un à Bastia
et un à ajaacio ces dépôts appartiennent
aux compagnies pétrolières et sont gérés
par Elf les détails en Corse achète le
litre 30 centimes moins cher que leurs
homologues continentaux pourquoi parce
que pour compenser les coûts de
distribution l'État leur accorde une
détaxe et pourtant ici les prix à la
pompe sont plus élevés que sur le
territoire environ 15 à 20 centimes de
plus ces tarifs sont fixés par deux
syndicats de détaillants le Conseil de
la concurrence saisi par le ministre des
Finances les soupçonne de s'entendre sur
les prix un exemple en janvier
Elf leur a proposé une opération
promotionnelle une baisse de 5 centimes
sur le litre les détaillants ont répondu
qu'ils ne répercuteraiit pas la ristour
aus clients sous-entendu qu'il la
garderaiit pour eux l'opération a été
étouffée dans l'œuf personne ne l'a su
décidé à faire éclater les choses au
grand jour le ministre des Finances
vient de demander à Elf de retenter une
baisse des prix autre prix dans le
collimateur celui du ciment et celui du
pain destiné aux collectivités dans les
deux cas on constate que les commerçants
ou les grossistes s'entendent pour
pratiquer les mêmes de prix ou pour ne
pas répercuter les baisses c'est le
Conseil de la concurrence qui devra
juger si ces pratiques sont illégales il
aura forte affaire car en Corse
s'intéresser au commerce s diton
s'attaquer au clan mauvais pass pour
Jean-Pierre de Peretti il a perdu
dimanche dernier la mairie d'exen-
Provence le voici aujourd'hui inculpé de
corruption de recell et d'abus de biens
sociaux il est le premier homme
politique à être ainsi touché trois
autres inculpations ont été signifié
aujourd'hui dans l'affaire des fausses
factures qui agite le sud-est depuis
plusieurs semaines Dominique
therce et oui il n'a décidément pas de
chance dimanche soir Jean-Pierre de
Peretti apprenait sa défaite et à peine
sorti de l'Hôtel de Ville d'exenprovence
le voilà inculpé de corruption et recè
d'abus de biens sociaux durant sa
campagne électorale Jean-Pierre de
Peretti avait répondu à plusieurs
reprises aux rumeurs qu'il assimilait au
trafic de fauses factures de la S MAE la
S MAE n'a pas un marché alors je vois
pas très bien comment je pourrais
surfacturer ou faussement facturer quoi
que ce soit avec la sorma je suis
tranquille je dors bien je ne prends pas
de médication et je suis en pleine forme
et je suis prêt à affronter une campagne
y compris avec cet ensemble très
calomnieux injurieux pourtant c'est le
directeur général de l'entreprise de
travaux publics lui-même Paul Pelletier
qui accuse il aurait versé 70000 francs
en liquide à l'ancien maire une une
liste de pot de vin avait d'ailleurs été
saisie par la police au domicile de Paul
Pelletier mais aujourd'hui comme hier
Jean-Pierre de Peretti conteste
l'accusation autres inculpés du dossier
un cadre d'une société d'équipement de
la ville d'exanprovence ainsi que Jul
Suzini l'ancien adjoint RPR de deetti il
est lui aussi soupçonné d'avoir touché
de l'argent pour faciliter quelques
marchés de travaux public à Marseille
c'est l'ancien directeur de cabinet de
Michel PZ qui est visé mat auraient
accepté 100000 francs contre des appels
d'offre truqué après avoir incarcéré
certains professionnels du bâtiment le
juge culier s'intéresse au versant
politique de l'affaire des fausses
factures et d'autres élus seront sans
doute inculpés dans les jours qui
viennent un civil prend la tête des
services secrets français Claude
zilberzan jusqu'ici préfet a été nommé
ce matin en conseil des ministres Hervé
brugini il est en uniforme et oui c'est
un civil monsieur Monsieur le Préfet en
a maintenant terminé avec les cérémonies
officielles Claude zilbertsan devient un
homme de l'ombre voici le nouveau patron
de la
DGSE ce sont des agents de la DGSE qui
ont coulé ce bateau affire Greenpeace à
l'époque Claude zilbertsan était au
cabinet de Laurent Fabius et y avait
affronté le sensible dossier il s'est
occupé aussi de la Nouvelle-Calédonie à
présent à la tête des services spéciaux
il envisage modestement sa future tâche
d'abord essayer de comprendre ce qu'elle
a dé GSE GSE personne ne la connaît sauf
ceux qui sont à l'intérieur de cette
maison elle est par essence étanche et
donc connaître la DGS avant d'avoir tout
programme le civil Claude zilberersan
sait qu'il aura forte àaire avec les
militaires de l'institution des GSE
amiral lacos général imbau général
Mermet tous militaire tous expatrons du
service jusqu'ici c'était eux qui
avaient le pouvoir le haut fonctionnaire
pierre Marion n'ayant été qu'un
intermède et puis la structure est
malade la play Greenpeace ne s'est pas
refermé Claude zilbertsan n'ignore pas
qu'il devra toucher au cœur de
l'organisme l'état-major c'est avec le
remplacement des hommes que l'on
mesurera l'ampleur de l'action du
nouveau chef de la DGSE en tout cas le
préfet zilbertsan pourra s'adresser à un
autre préfet Bernard Gérard le
responsable de la DST le
contre-espionnage ensemble ils parleront
peut-être des réformes à venir dans ces
deux institutions du
renseignement oublions un peu les
affaires et PARLONS SANTÉ la nouvelle
vient de Marseille elle apporte un peu
d'espoir dans la lutte menée par les les
chercheurs et les médecins contre la
muscovicidose cette anomalie génétique
la plus fréquente de toutes qui conduit
souvent à la destruction des poumons il
nait chaque jour un enfant ainsi atteint
une équipe marseillaise a tenté il y a
10 mois une première mondiale le
remplacement des poumon d'un enfant
malade par ceux d'un donneur opération
réussie on en est maintenant à 7 GREF de
ce genre Alain Labous et François
Granier ont retrouvé aux alentours de
Marseille quelquesuns de ces petits
miraculés Sophie la première enfant au
monde atteinte de mucovicidose à avoir
été transplanté c'était le 23 mai 88
Christophe greffé le 29 janvier dernier
il savait qu'il n'avait plus que 15
jours à vivre Stéphanie condamnée comme
les autres est sauvé elle aussi in
extrémist tous vont bien aujourd'hui
mais ils ont eu de la chance comme
Laurent le dernier des greffé
bipulmonaires c'était dimanche dernier
ici à Marseille pour lui aussi tout
semble s'être bien
passé une des choses fantastiques quand
on remplace le poumon de ses enfants et
de voir la différence entre le poumon
avant quand on l'ouvre les branches on a
l'impression de voir s'écouler du tube
dentifrice et puis quand on les a
remplacé tout d'un coup ils sont roses
ils avaient une pression d'oxygène très
très basse ils ont une pression
d'oxygène après qui devient normal
l'heure des bilan SEP enfants ont été
greffés à Marseille et déjà C succès CIN
fois des enfants ont dû réapprendre à
vivre recommencer à faire des projets je
le son mieux dans ma peau
quoi moins
angoissé on prend la vie
différemment avant je vivais au jour le
jour parce que je savais que s'il y
aurait pas eu la greffe je serais
sûrement pas là mais maintenant je vis
avec l'avenir ça leur a permis de de
retrouver une vie normale de pouvoir
marcher de pouvoir courir alors qu'avant
bon enfin pour le cas de Sophie elle
était condamnée à rester dans son lit le
moindre effort lui coûtait lui coûtait
énormément elle ne quittait pas sa
chambre comme Sophie stéphanie est
étonnante elle était mourante il y a à
peine 5 mois aujourd'hui elle a déjà le
chemin de son club de
sport
cont pu j'aV l'image de
sopiecoup pas le
CH je
Gy je faire
ten
qui pour les sauver est àter deain des
chercheurs mais à l'heure qu'il est si
leur état s'agrave brusquement pour eu
il n'y a qu'une seule
solution
j'attends c'est le se pour l'stant qu'on
a
guérison va-t-on retrouver dans la
Manche une semaine après l'avoir perdu
ce dangereux conteneur alourdi d'un
pesticide hautement toxique TR bateaux
de la marine national on rejoint un
chasseur de mine à l'endroit où hier
l'échou du sonnard révélait la présence
d'un objet métallique
brunoex le Clio de retour de mission
avec ses 50 membres d'équipage acqua
dans le port de Cherbourg l'un des deux
chasseurs de mine est rentré cet
après-midi de la zone de recherche en
raison d'une très mauvaise météo ce
matin un nouvel écho capté par le
sonnard a confirmé l'existence d'une
boîte métallique de 4 à 5 m de long la
présence du conteneur de l'indal au
large de rini ne fait maintenant presque
de doute on peut dire à 90 à 95 % c'est
un conteneur qui est au pond maintenant
savoir si c'est le contenur qu'on
cherche ça il faut le voir pour
identifier avec certitude le conteneur
de l'indan ce poisson autopropulsé
quiéquipe les chasseurs de mine de la
Marine nationale 700 kg 3 m de long ce
PAP est muni d'une caméra et d'un
projecteur sous son ventre une charge
explosive utilisé pour le déminage il
est capable de plonger à plus de 120 m
de de profondeur d'une autonomie d'une
heure et dem il est relié par une bobine
électrique au PC du navire c'est là
qu'il transmet les informations et
permet la visualisation des fonds marins
le conteneur de l'indane identifié il
faudra ensuite le renflouer des robots
submersibles ou des engins submersibles
habités tels que ceux qui ont été pour
prendre quelque chose de récent sur
Lespes du titanque où les plongées qui
ont été effectuées au large de Cherbourg
sur l'épave de l'Alabama avec ces engins
là on doit pouvoir trouver une solution
pour remonter le container quand à
l'pave du perintis il git toujours à
plus de 100 m de fond au large de La
Hague en zone britannique dans ces du
permétrine et du cmériine pesticide
d'une haute toxicité pour l'instant
aucun navire n' sembleil effectué de
prélèvement d'eau de mer afin de repérer
d'éventuell
pollution l'écologie gagne la politique
et pas seulement en cas tion le Parti
communiste italien a conclu aujourd'hui
son congrès annuel la décision qui
provoque le plus de commentaires
l'interdiction de fumer pendant les
réunions des militants une décision
approuvée il faut bien le dire à une
courte majorité la nuit dernière c'est
en tout cas un aperçu du changement de
style du PCI dont les têtes dirigeantes
se demandaient même il y a quelques
jours s'il ne fallait pas lui trouver un
nouveau nom pour lutter contre son
relatif déclin le Parti Communiste
Italien accentue ses différences à Rome
Marc le message le plus ovationné par
les 1042 délégués au 18e congrès du
Parti Communiste Italien celui de michil
Gorbatchev on est loin de la rupture
fracassante de 1982 avec le parti de
breev englué dans l'aventure meurtrière
de l'intervention en Afghanistan des
communistes qui ont su prendre à temps
tous les virages de l'histoire et qui se
considèrent un peu aujourd'hui comme les
inspirateurs de la pche tro pourtant
depuis la mort en 198
du leader charismatique enri berlinger
le PCI ne cessait de décliner après
avoir fait presque jeu égal avec la
démocratie chrétienne à plus de 30 % des
suffrages il tombit aux élections
provinciales partielles de l'automne
dernier à 21 %. mais les communistes
italien en profitent aussitôt pour se
distinguer à nouveau leur secrétaire
général Alexandro nata tire les
conséquences de ses échecs et
démissionne un geste inédit dans le
monde communiste à leur tête aujourd'hui
un homme de 53 ans Akil oketto
entouré d'une équipe rajunie il entraîne
son parti dans ce qu'il appelle le
nouveau cours une plus grande attention
aux problèmes écologiques au
revendication féministe au droit de
l'individu mais surtout une déroutante
politique étrangère qui rapproche de
plus en plus le PCI des socialistes
français et surtout des socio-démocrates
allemands à l'intérieur de ce qu'il
appelle l'euro gauche un parti de plus
en plus réformiste et qui s'impatiente
de piétiner aux portes du pouvoir le
problème pour une grande force de
changement c'est de conduire
transformation historique ce n'est pas
d'attendre leur hache où le capitalisme
tombera comme un frumur parce que
entre-etemps on risque d'être de moins
en moins nombreux et alors l'heure
fatidique risque fort de ne jamais
arriver l'un des moments forts de ce
congrès la visite du frère ennemi
betinocraxi secrétaire général du Parti
socialiste italien il ne cesse de
polémiquer avec ces étranges communistes
un peu trop enclins à lui disputer
l'espace d'une gauche réformiste et
antistalinienne les uns et les autres
savent bien pourtant que la seule
alternative possible à l'alliance
actuelle si difficile entre les
socialistes et la démocratie chrétienne
c'est l'union de la gauche reste à
savoir lequel de ces deux hommes sera le
patron de la maison commune Craxi ou
oketo et c'est toute la
question même que les communistes
italiens pourraient rejoindre au
Parlement de Strasbourg le groupe
social-démocrate Cambodge année Z0
c'était il y a 10 ans l'armée
vietnamienne intervenait dans ce petit
pays désormais maudit par s dieux et
chasser le sinistre popotte et ses
rouges aujourd'hui les troupes
vietnamiennes se retirent le Cambodge
s'efforce de renaître et d'effacer ses
cauchemars c'est ce qu'on constaté
là-bas Jean-Marc Ilous et Philippe péter
ils en reviennent leur premiè
portage Cambodge en 10 après le
génocide revenu le temps des enfants et
des
offrandes le temps des pagodes et de la
ferveur
ferveur lourde de cauchemar pour ceux
qui remercient encore le Seigneur Boudha
d'avoir survécu à
l'horreur avril 75 janvier 79 l'horreur
absolu la folie sad du régime rouge
transforme le Cambodge en un gigantesque
camp de concentration exécution torture
famine font plus d'un million de morts
Pnom Pen sa population déportée restera
une ville fantôme jusqu'à l'intervention
de l'armée vietnamienne et la fuite
desmer
rouges P pe 89 déjà plus de 700000
habitants en dépit des apparences une
ville pauvre mais qui a repris goût aux
choses de la
vie Pnom Pen les rouges n'y ont plus
frappé depuis 3 ans même si sur les
routes de campagne leur continue de
mutiler pomen capitale d'un État reconnu
par les seuls alliés du Vietnam et de
l'URSS la République populaire du
campouia la
RPK copie conforme du Vietnam sur le
papier certainement et
encore en matière économique la RPK ne
cherche guère à résister aux assauts de
l'économie de
marché
on s'en fout qu'on a communiste non
l'essentiel c'est dire élever le niveau
de vie des gens construire le pays
rapidement et essayer d'atteindre un
certain niveau de développement
satisfaisant désormais tout converge de
nouveau vers les marchés de Pnom Pen
produits
locaux marchandises volé mais surtout
importation plus ou moins clandestine de
Thaïlande comme ces véllo flamban neu le
gouvernement prélève une taxe
forfaitaire et ferme systématiement les
yeux priorité au
commerce signe de l'ASP rassurant de ce
communisme débon à la cambodgienne
l'argent chinois qui sur l'axe Hong Kong
Singapour sauté depuis 1975 l'escale de
pnomen a retrouvé les chemins du
Cambodge en Asie cela se sa et compte
surtout pour la monnaie à l'inverse d'un
Vietnam rongé par l'inflation le
Cambodge voit sa monnaie rester presque
stable par rapport à
l'or un atout insuffisant pour
reconstruire le pays mais appréciable
pour contourner les incertitudes
politiques du moment et recréer un
climat de relative
confiance ce jour-là cette famille
rencontrée par hasard pendait la
crémaillère dans le quartier on navait
pas vu pareil fit depuis 14
[Musique]
ans encore des obus et la peur dans le
réduit chrétien du Liban à Beyrouth le
port et la partie chrétienne de la ville
ont été à nouveau bombardé aujourd'hui
l'armée syrienne et ses alliés
continuent d'encercler la région
plusieurs milliers de Libanais fuitent
maintenant vers le sud dans la zone
contrôlée par Israël craignant la
confrontation entre les Syriens et les
forces du général Aoun qui s'y déclare
prêt le ministre syrien des Affaires
étrangères et lui en ce moment à Paris
il a été reçu ce matin par le président
mitan pierre serra l'a
rencontré Farou alchar un homme à priori
affable chargé d'une mission délicate
démontré à Paris que le Liban dominé par
la Syrie demeure libre de ses choix
politiques ces choix politiques sont
limités en fait par l'occupation
israélienne du Sud Liban en violation
avec la résolution 425 des Nations Unies
oui mais l'occupation syrienne au nord
dans les rest du pays mêmeetoccupation
israélienne pour votre information nous
sommes là-bas sur invitation les
israliens sont là-bas par
invasion vationu vie votreé se comporte
en d'occupation
mainten n
pas en tête comme certains médias
occidentaux jusqu'à quand comptez-vous
rester au
Liban nous resterons au Liban tant que
les Libanais le souhaiteront c'est un
devoir national pour nous bien sûr nous
voudrions quitter le Liban le plus tôt
possible c'estàdire dès que les Libanais
pourront se réconcilier et arrêteront de
s'entretuer je vous remercie
beaucoup disgrâce et la honte c'est
ainsi que l'imam Khomeini qualifie le
retour en Iran des ambassadeurs
européens décidés par les pays de la
Communauté ils y reviennent humiliés
a-t-il dit dans un message à la nation
iranienne aujourd'hui pour alimenter
sans qu'on l'oublie l'affaire red je
vous signale cet intéressant sondage que
publie le prochain numéro du Nouvel
Observateur les musulmans français sont
très partagé sur l'affaire Rochdi roched
est fautif pour 34 % d'entre eux le même
pourcentage en vœ à comen 32 % se disent
sans
opinion en Grande-Bretagne l'affaire qui
passionne désormais l'opinion a changé
de forme les services britanniques ont
fourni une bien jolie proie au journaux
à sensation elle s'appelle Pamela borde
elle est indienne elle avait épousé un
français elle accorde ou plutôt elle
vend ses grâces à toutes sortes d'hommes
importants au chocking certains sont
mariés et pire ils ne sont pas tous
britannique
Philippe un scandale c'est comme une
mayonnaise quelque fois ça prend quelque
fois pas dans le cas de l'affaire
profumo la belle Christine killer qui
dans les années 60 partageait ses
moments d'intimité avec le ministre de
la guerre profumo et un diplomate
soviétique le scandale a eu un tel
retentissement qu'aujourd'hui on en a
fait un film numéro 1 au box office dans
le cas de Pamela Bordes ancienne Miss
Inde les choses se présentent moins bien
certes le fait que la belle Pamela
travaillait le jour à la Chambre des
communes et la nuit comme colgir dans
une autre chambre a attiré l'attention
d'autant qu'on l'a vu photographier avec
des spécimens du tout Londres dont le
ministre des Sports Colin monian
shocking mais insuffisant pour faire un
scandale on va donc lui trouver une
relation avec non pas Kaddafi mais un de
ses cousins attaché au service secret
libien là ça devient plus sérieux dans
un pays la Grande-Bretagne fâ avec la
lib et on ne plaisante pas avec la
sécurité alors espion terroriste il
existe une autre thèse ce serait tout
simplement un coup publicitaire la belle
Pamel aujourd'hui évanouie ressurgirait
pour raconter ses aventures
croustillantes dans un livre puis un
film qui rapporterait encore plus
d'argent que ce consacré à l'affaire
profumo il fallait y penser dans le
centre de l'Angleterre aujourd'hui
explosion meurtrière devant une usine é
Perin
un mort 67 blessés bilan provisoire de
l'explosion d'un camion transportant du
matériel pour une fabrique de feu
d'artifice l'accident a eu lieu au cœur
de la zone industrielle de peterbough
située à 120 km au nord de Londres la
violente déflagration a détruit au moins
six bâtiments arracher les toits de
certaines habitations avoisinantes et
souffler les vitres de tout le
quartier hospitalisation dans un état
désespéré de Thierry Paulin le jeune
homme inculpé pour l'assassinat de 18
vieilles dames entre 84 et 86 il se
savait sopositif depuis 2 ans son procès
n'aura sans doute jamais
lieu 41 kg de cocaïne pure saisie à
saintraaphaël sur la Côte d'Azur parmi
les personnes interpellées Pasqual
Claudio Locatelli un important
trafiquant italien lié à la mafia qui
cherchait à mettre en place un réseau
international entre la Colombie et
l'Europe
échec d'un tir expérimental de missile
tridant au large de la Floride l'engin
lancé par un sous-marin a échappé à tout
contrôle au bout de 4 secondes cet
incident qui a coûté 160 millions de
francs et surtout une lourde déception
pour la marine
américaine le bon le joueur et le
méchant ce pourrait être le titre du
feuilleton qui passionne le monde des
jeux le héros s'appelle Darwin Hortis il
a étudié les lois de la probabilité il
joue 6 par jour au et au D il vient
d'être embauché par le casino de daville
Dominique Verdean nous dit
pourquoi il se prénomme Darwin et il
appartient à une race en voie de
disparition celle des manipulateurs
honnêtes C des tapis ver a fait un choix
sa dextérité sa mémoire son entraînement
de 6 he par jour il les met au service
de la lutte antifraud dans les casino
Darwin hor a décidé de jouer carte sur
table il triche dans la plus parfaite
légalité
cela vient de mes parents qui m'ont
appris à rester du côté de la loi j'y
trouve plus de plaisir ainsi je dors mie
la nuit pour moi c'est un meilleur style
de
vie hier à il a révélé au physionomist
professionnel tour de passp qui coûte
parfois gros casin
trdu0000 une seule soirée
iWin en douce deux cartes peu favorables
au jeu qu'il a en
main la triche se développe parce que de
nouvelles technologies sont utilisées
comme de mini caméras vidéo caché dans
une montre qui enregistre la vitesse de
rotation du cylindre ou d'une bille
d'une roulette et des écouteurs qui
permettent au tricheurs de communiquer
entre
eux obsession de ce dingue du poker ne
pas connaître la dernière arnaque de
mise dans les établissements de de jeu
dernière révélation Darwin orti consomme
pas moins de 600 cartes à jeu par
an du jeu à Pierrette Bress en passant
par les pronostics pour le tiercé et le
cararté à huteuil de main le 5 le 7 le 6
le 4 le 2 le 12 le 9 et le 15 dans un
instant Laurent Cabrol vous parlera du
temps de demain vers 23h 15 Henri sagier
vous donnera les dernières informations
de la journée demain matin 6h45
rendez-vous avec Télématin à 7h45 c'est
Edmond charlerou qui répondra aux
questions de Gérard Morin elle parlera
bien sûr des résultats des élections à
Marseille et aussi de ces de son très
beau livre désir d'Orient très bonne
soirée sur Antenne 2 à demain
[Musique]
20h